Ilhan Omar and Rashid a Talib
propagandize on behalf of anti-israel
and anti-semitic BDS the media ignore
all of their priorities as per our usual
arrangement and president from tries to
take control on the economy I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
a lot of news to get to today including
an actual good development from Facebook
yes really an actual good development
from Facebook we'll get to all of that
in just one second first geopolitical
tensions are rising you just read the
news or listen to this show obviously
there's a lot of uncertainty at best
about the economy gold prices are moving
up again as people attempt to find
shelter from the economic vicissitudes
inherent in the economy either in gold
or in places like bonds that's why I see
the bond curve in the yield curve in
Beart because people are so worried
about the future of the economy it's
also why the price of gold has been
going up well you should at least be
diversified some of your savings should
in fact be in precious metals can you
afford another hit to your retirement
like the debt last downturn when the S&P
dropped 50% probably not shouldn't you
be protecting yourself well I protect
myself by talking with my friends over
at Birch gold I know them I trust them
it's a great way to hedge against
inflation and uncertainty and
instability precious metals my savings
plan is diversified yours should be as
well Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals again you buy that gold
to hold that gold the whole point of it
is to ensure that you are not screwed
over by central banks you're not screwed
over by a market that could drop at any
moment or could drop sometime in the
future is why you diversify you can get
their comprehensive 16-page kit
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit text Ben - 47 47 47
again text Ben my name - 47 47 47 that
has been - 47 47 47 okay so the
Democratic Party is deciding right now
rat whether they are going to move in
the radical direction or whether they
are going to move in the moderate
direction if they wish to win elections
they should obviously move in a moderate
direction because all they had to do was
not be crazy
that's all they had to do they're
running against a president who did not
win a majority of the popular vote and
whose approval ratings are
extraordinarily low on average all they
have to do is not be crazy and they
simply cannot do it apparently instead
the Democrats have decided that the best
available policy is to center all of
their attention and focus on defending
the most radical of their members that's
because that's where they think the
passion is
Democrats now believe that they're going
to win over the moderates because
President Trump is so off-putting the
biggest threat to them is that a bunch
of people on the woke left will not show
up to vote the same way they didn't show
up to vote in 2016 in the Democratic
view the reason that Hillary Clinton
lost is because moderates showed up to
vote for her and base did not show up to
vote for her and there's truth to that
they look forward to 2020 and they say
okay well moderates will probably show
up to vote for us we got to get that
base out that means that we are going to
censor all of our attention on defending
the most radical among us well that's
making an assumption that may not be in
evidence which is that moderates will
certainly swing to the Democratic Party
because remember moderates voted for
Hillary Clinton because they believed I
think wrongly that Hillary Clinton was a
moderate but if Democrats were
denominated on a presidential level
somebody who is radical well that
changes the ballgame radically and the
same thing is true in Congress if it
turns out that the Democratic Congress
cannot be trusted with power if it looks
to the American people like that
Congress is going to perform in radical
polarized partisan fashion they will not
vote for the Democrats this is why what
you saw at the end of 2018 is pretty
important right before the election
about a month and a half out from the
election the Republicans had a
significant generic ballot deficit
against the Democrats they were down
eight to ten points in the generic
ballot then the Cavanaugh hearings
happened about three weeks out from the
election and those Cavanagh hearings
closed up that gap tighter than a tech I
mean it was extremely tight all of a
sudden and that's because the more the
American people saw of Democrats acting
radical the more they saw of Democrats
acting foolishly and badly the less they
wanted to vote for them and then of
course a couple weeks before the
election President Trump was sick of
being out of the headlines and he
decided he was going to go out in
campaign and that immediately drove the
gap wide again well the Democrats have
decided that they are going to ignore
the possibility that they are alienating
people and instead they are going to
focus in on Trump Trump is the be-all
end-all
it's a risky strategy for sure and so
what you're seeing right now is this
divide inside the Democratic Party now
when I say the Democrats are doing this
I don't mean all Democrats there is this
fight going on inside the Democratic
Party and you can see it reflected in
the polling in the Democratic primaries
so Joe Biden for all of the crap that
has been tossed his way for all of the
talk about Joe Biden fading and
Elizabeth Warren rising Joe Biden is
basic
was a month ago in the polls in the
overall national polls he still has an
extraordinarily wide lead
he still has a narrow lead in places
like New Hampshire in Iowa he still has
a narrow lead has a very wide lead in
places like South Carolina as soon as he
gets to the South where there's a heavy
share of black voting then Joe Biden
suddenly jumps into this massive lead
because Kamala Harris has no support in
the black community and Elizabeth Warren
has no support among black voters
there's a brand new pull out from CNN
today and it shows that Joe Biden has
actually expanded his edge over the
Democratic field in a new CNN poll 29%
of Democrats and democratic-leaning
registered voters say they back former
Vice President Biden that is up 7%
compared with the late June CNN survey
no other candidate has made meaningful
gains over that time Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren are still stuck in this
internecine fight for the Socialist Left
Bernie Sanders is at 15% Elizabeth
Warren is at 14% according to the CNN
poll the only statistically meaningful
change in the candidates standings is a
12-point decline in support for Kamala
Harris who right after the first debate
in June was up at 17% and now has
dropped all the way back down to 5% ouch
ouch Tulsi Gabbard Wow turns out that
Tulsi Gabbard clocking Kamala Harris
into the next county basically may have
destroyed Kamala Harris as a candidate
the original June CNN poll was conducted
in the days immediately following the
first round of the DNC debates Biden's
performance was panned and Harris's was
praised well now she has dropped all the
way back down to Pete Budaj edge levels
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren are
exactly where they were before they may
have flip-flopped for one point and Joe
Biden is all the way back up at 29
Biden's advantage in this poll is
boosted by stronger support from
self-identified Democrats 31% than from
Independence 23% older voters 34% than
younger ones 23% among those aged 44
under age 45 and from moderate and
conservative voters so he's getting a
lot of support among Democrats older
voters and moderate and conservative
voters so that is the fight inside the
Democratic Party is the newly woke
plurality of the Democratic Party in
control or is it the large segment that
supported Hillary Clinton in 2016 that
supported Hillary
probably in 2008 against Barack Obama
those folks combined with a serious
share of the black vote could propel Joe
Biden to victory so this is a serious in
fight inside the Democratic Party and
you're starting to see this have
ramifications in terms of how the
candidates approach policy so for
example the Washington Post reports
today that Democrats are now backing off
their once fervent embrace of Medicare
for all
so Kamala Harris among other Democrats
is starting to recognize that running
hard to the left there's no room over
there now I've been saying this since
the beginning of the primaries I've been
saying that any candidate who found the
spine to run in the face of the
progressive woke left in their own party
would actually do pretty well given that
they got some sort of media attention so
it wasn't gonna help somebody like
Michael Bennett who nobody knew who he
was but when people judge first
announced and was acting like a moderate
he started climbing in the polls then he
started acting like a radical and he
declined again in the polls and he's
been stagnant ever since
well Kamala Harris is starting to
recognize that playing a sort of mini
version of Elizabeth Warren isn't gonna
work anymore and she is moving again so
she's moving her positions up down and
all around according to the Washington
Post leaning back on AB leather black
leather sofa as her campaign bus rumbled
toward Fort Dodge Kamala Harris tried to
explain why she spent months defending a
plan to replace private health insurance
with Medicare for all only to switch to
a more modest proposal that would allow
private insurance to continue after all
Harris said I don't think it was any
secret I was not entirely comfortable
that's an understatement I was finally
like I can't make this circle fit into a
square I said we're gonna take hits
people are gonna say she's waffling it's
gonna be awful but she said she decided
it was worth it actually what happened
is that she thought that all of the
political gain was to be made in the
Medicare for all space it turns out that
space was crowded and now she's bumper
carring it off of that particular crash
and trying to move into Joe Biden's Lane
according to the Washington Post the
Democratic senator from California is
hardly alone the idea of Medicare for
all a unified government health program
that would take over the basic function
of private insurance became a liberal
litmus test at the outset of the
presidential campaign but in recent
months several of the Democratic
hopefuls have shifted their positions or
their tone moderating full-throated
endorsement of Medicare for all
adopting ideas for allowing private
insurance in some form worth noting
Kamala Harris was a co-sponsor of Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all bill
Oh for all this oh I was well-known I
was uncomfortable was it though was it
really I mean about the time that you
were signing right next to Bernie
Sanders on the medicare-for-all bill was
it well known that you were
uncomfortable with Bernie Sanders's
medicare-for-all bill don't think so
near a tangent who's a former top aide
to Hillary Clinton and president of the
Center for American Progress she says
what I think has happened in the
Democratic primary is people recognize
that some of the concerns about
single-payer are not coming from special
interests but the public former former
Texas congressman mater O'Rourke is
doing the same thing he originally
embraced Medicare for all is the best
way he now similarly supports a plan
that would preserve the current employer
based insurance system ok so the gap is
beginning to open up wide between the
progressive left and these so-called
moderates in the Democratic Party and
this is being led by Elizabeth Warren
who's again trying to steal away support
from Bernie Sanders and also trying to
cut into the black level of support for
Joe Biden she's doing this by attacking
Joe Biden's crime policies and she's
also attacking Kamala Harris's crime
policies and Cory Booker's crime
policies so Elizabeth Warren trying to
outflank all of them on the left by
basically calling Kamala Harris and Joe
Biden cops The Washington Post reports
that Elizabeth Warren said on Tuesday
that his president should eliminate the
death penalty and the use of private
prisons curtailed the cash bail system
and overhaul the use of presidential
pardons the announcement was Warren's
entry into the volatile debate over
criminal justice reform an issue that is
resonating especially in the
african-american community now again I
don't know where the Washington Post is
getting these numbers that the issue is
resonating especially in the black
community if that were true you would
expect that Donald Trump would have seen
a significant uptick in support from the
black community considering that the
dude signed into law criminal justice
reform
you would also expect that the attacks
on Joe Biden by Kamala Harris would have
borne some sort of serious repercussions
given her attacks on him over his 1994
crime bill they have not so I think that
is an assumption that is being made that
I'm not seeing a lot of statistical
support for us that the black community
is deeply entranced and entranced with
the idea of criminal justice reform
unlike earlier policy announcements
Warren did not hesitate to take implicit
but unmistakable aim at policies
embraced in the past by her rivals
especially former VP Joe Biden senators
Kamala
and Cory Booker Lauren said we will
reduce incarceration and prove justice
in our country by changing what we
choose to criminalize reforming police
behavior and improving police community
relations and reining in a system that
preferences prosecution over justice
well actually the system preferences
criminal justice pleas over prosecution
to be real most people plead out their
cases because they are guilty and they
know it and they don't want to go to
jail for longer by going through the
actual the actual burden of a trial I
love this sort of sloganeering will
reduce incarceration so you'll without
reducing the levels of crime you'll
reduce incarceration how wouldn't that
imply that there will be more criminals
on the street I mean simply by dint of
statistical analysis and when she says
by choosing what we buy changing what we
choose to criminalize well we've already
decriminalized marijuana in the state of
California and we solve a lot of people
in prison in the state of California
they've done it in Washington State
they've done it in Colorado so a lot of
people in prison because it turns out
that the vast vast vast majority of
people in prison in the United States
are not in prison for a simple drug
possession many of them are in prison
for drug distribution and most of them
are still in prison for other crimes we
broke down those statistics in a podcast
maybe two weeks ago three weeks ago but
obviously this is political pandering
and it's war and attempting to cut into
the black base of support by moving
radical and you're seeing the entire
Democratic Party not playing this game
and it's not just the presidential
candidates it's the entire Democratic
Party trying to have it both ways trying
to capture these zeitgeist of the
radical progressives while at the same
time trying to appeal to moderates and
that's a hard bridge to gap now Trump
could make it a lot harder for them to
gap by not being so off the wall all the
time
if Trump appeared to be a steady calming
influence in American politics then that
gap would open wide we saw this just a
month ago when Nancy Pelosi and AOC
looked like they were about to beat each
other over the head with live claw
hammers and then Trump jumped in it was
like hold up a second Leroy Jenkins and
decided that he was just going to
Bigfoot that entire conversation and
become the center of attention
Trump right now is papering over a lot
of the internal Democratic gaps but
those gaps do exist and they are and
they're going to widen in the near
future I'll explain how this is
happening on a congressional level in
just one second first let's talk about
big tech particularly Twitter okay there
lot of these big tech companies will
discuss one actually in a little while
that I think is attempting to make some
good moves but there are a lot of big
tech companies that are not particularly
friendly to conservatives Twitter my
personal Bugaboo a company then not only
is not friendly to conservatives and
throws them off the platform some of
them without any actual proper
explanation but decides what trends in
obviously biased ways well if you can't
trust certain elements in Silicon Valley
to treat conservatives fairly how can
you trust them to handle your privacy
and personal online data that's why I
recommend using expressvpn every time
you go online big tech companies can use
your IP address to match your internet
activity it's your identity or location
I'm not just talking about the the big
tech companies you know about there are
many apps that are doing this there are
many companies you don't think about
that are doing this when I use
expressvpn search engines and media
sites can't see my IP address at all my
identity is masked and anonymous
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting a hundred percent of your
data to keep you safe from people who
don't want to have your data express it
VPNs software takes just a minute to set
up on your computer or phone it tap one
button you are then protected so if
you're like me and you believe that your
internet data belongs to you and not to
giant tech companies who may not be
friendly to your view then expressvpn is
the answer protect your online activity
today with the VPN I trust to keep my
data safe visit expressvpn comm slash
Ben to claim an exclusive offer for my
fans
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with one year package
visit Express at VPN comm slash Ben to
get started okay so as I say this battle
between the woke progressives and I keep
saying woke because woke is sort of an
internally used term in progressive
circles to denote people who have the
right views on issues and then link them
with racial views right that is the idea
that woken is result of woke miss
results from identifying race at the
center of American life intersectional
politics at the center of American life
that's what I mean when I talk about the
woke progressives versus sort of the
moderate Democrat so-called moderate
Democrats when you're seeing this play
out in real time in Congress so if the
Democratic Party were smart they would
be featuring people like representative
Abigail Spann Stan burger so you've
never heard of representative Abigail
Spann burger why because she's a
moderate from Virginia and Democrats
don't want to feature her which makes
very little sense considering that
representative Spann burger is exactly
the sort of candidate the demo
that's need in order to win a majority
now Nancy Pelosi knows this which is why
Nancy Pelosi has openly stated in the
past that all of those purple districts
are the ones she has to worry about not
Ilhan Omar's district not receded to
lieb's district those are pure blue
districts not a o'seas district but span
Berger is getting clocked on all sides
for the crime of being a moderate in the
Democratic Party according to the
Washington Post at the end of another
long week in Congress representative
Abigail Spann burger poured herself a
cup of coffee and waited in her DC
apartment for her family to arrive from
their home outside Richmond
she felt satisfied with a job well done
then she looked at Twitter the Democrats
how liberals lashing out at moderates
like herself for approving 4.6 billion
dollars in emergency aid for migrants at
the southern border a deal they said did
little to rein in the Trump
administration's immigration policies
representative mark Pocan of Wisconsin
accused lawmakers like Span Berger of
being part of a child abuse caucus the
chief of staff for AOC said their vote
would enable a racist system on facebook
spam Berger was labeled too late and
clueless Twitter by the way is a massive
bubble that has very little impact on
real-world thinking which is why members
of the media who spent an enormous time
on Twitter seems to think that that's
real life
that is not how people actually think
which lifespan burger is much more
important to Democrats in real world
time then our Ilhan omar and rashida to
leave but that's not how the Democrats
are treating them span Berger was
stunned it was the first time the
freshman congresswoman could not make
sense of what was happening reflecting
on the late June episode span Berger
said she learned a hard lesson she did
not anticipate in 2018 when she unseated
Republican Dave brat and helps Democrats
win the House Majority sometimes your
biggest foes will be in your own party
in the eight months span Berger has
served in Congress she's been a lawmaker
in the middle
she comes from a historically Republican
district that just five years ago
replaced Eric Cantor with someone more
conservative but she won last year in
large part thanks to left-leaning groups
like the liberal women of Chesterfield
County
she beat brat by just two points she's a
district Democrats need to keep doesn't
matter Democrats are attacking her
she says that week showed me that for
some people ideology matters more than
putting food in the mouth of a child and
that was stunning to me now if you are
Donald Trump if you are a Republican
looking forward to 2020 then maybe you
celebrate the fact that span burger is
being ousted by her own party but if you
are just an American who
cares less about partisan politics than
you do about the future of a two-party
system you want people like span burger
to win not the sea but you want her to
defeat her more left-leaning colleagues
in Congress you want two viable parties
that are censored around where the
American people are not a party that is
running wildly to the left far away from
the American public and simply winning
on the basis of Republican unpopularity
right span burger is somebody that I
would like to see in a leadership
position in the Democratic Party and I
think most reasonable people would not
Ilhan omar initiated Talib and again i
don't want us here in congress i want to
see a Republican in Congress I like Dave
brat I'd like to see if Dave rap back in
Congress but if you are going to choose
between Democrats that choice does have
ramifications so there's a theory among
Republicans that it's better for
Democrats it's good for Democrats to
polarize and centralize around the
Elizabeth Warren's and around the ill
Hannah Mars and the Rashida to leaves
and the a OCS in the autumn the Ayanna
Presley's and that's good because the
American people look at that and in vote
Republican that's a dangerous game I
would much rather have a choice between
the Republican Party and a more
reasonable Democratic Party because that
means that the backstop of Republicans
losing isn't insanity I don't want a
choice between Republican and insane
that's a bad choice because well it may
mean the Republicans win more often it
also means that when they lose insane is
in charge and that is a dangerous
dangerous thing and that is what we are
seeing with the Democratic Party
rallying around
Ilhan Omar and Rashid it to lead so ill
head Omar mashita Talib are still being
championed by the top members of the
Democratic Party at this point and that
is insane and members of the media by
the way let's do a quick thought
exercise you did a little bit yesterday
on on the radio show but let's do a
quick thought exercise imagine for a
second that you had two white Republican
Congress men and they planned a trip to
Israel in conjunction with an
organization that had run pieces quoting
anti-semitic myths about Jews imbibing
Christian blood for passover matzah then
republished a neo-nazi article decrying
the jew controlled entertainment media
that suggested that terrorists who
murder Israeli children should be
honored imagine their white Republican
Congress people for a second do you
think that might be a story what if
those two sitting white Republican
congressman tweeted out a cartoon from a
cartoon is so anti-semitic he won second
prize that
Holocaust denial cartoon contest imagine
that these two white Republican Congress
men had themselves engaged in open
anti-semitic slurs ranging from a
suggestion that Israel's supporters in
America suffered from dual loyalty to
the accusation that Israel hypnotizes
the world to the suggestion that it's
all about the Benjamins American support
for Israel imagine these two white
Republican congressman had expressed
support for terrorists like razz me Oh
Deb imagine that both Congress people
had a long history of associations with
open anti-semites who hate Jews and
finally imagine that both white
Republican members of Congress we're
calling for a complete cut off of aid to
Israel as well as boycott divestment and
sanctions from Israel and demanded entry
to Israel do you think the story might
be the beliefs of the two white
Republican congressman or would it be
how mean Israel is to these people and
not allowing them to come we all know
the answer to this if we were talking
about Steve King and Pat Buchanan you
know as a representative then this would
be the story the story would be they're
evil terrible horrible no good very bad
beliefs however make these members of
Congress females of color who are Muslim
and suddenly the math completely shifts
and we are not allowed to talk about any
of this there is no mainstream media
coverage of any of these things and if
there is mainstream media coverage it's
about how audacious these women are how
they are raising issues that haven't
been thought of before you know issues
like whether Jews drink Christian blood
I mean that is literally what the group
that was sponsoring their trip has put
on their website this is this is where
the Democrats are they will defend
anything that these women do and they
will do so if it means justifying
full-on terrorism and anti-semitism this
became fairly clear yesterday when rich
Lowry of National Review is on CNN with
Peter Beinart
representative Hamas on CNN so Peter
Beinart writes for a bunch of
publications including the New Republic
in the nation Peter Beinart has always
been a representative of the pro Hamas
position in the in the Israel Hamas
israel-palestinian debate he has never
seen in action by Israel that he finds
appropriate he has always justified too
and he justified terrorism yesterday on
on CNN I mean on national television in
order to defend Omar and Talib this is
how far the left is willing to go to
defend these women specifically because
they're trying to again grab hold
the passionate base in in full knowledge
that they are alienating moderates in
the process here's by not being insane
Palestinians don't have to be Saints in
order deserve the basic rights that all
of us take for granted right
miffed I had an anti-semitic statement
they apologized for these are strong
supporters of the BDS movement they are
not honest brokers we wouldn't afford a
white nationalist organization the the
leeway that Peter is giving this
organization oh they're not Saints this
is an anti-semitic a group that
supported terrorism supports blowing up
innocent civilians and children and no
matter what you think of the dispute
between the Palestinians and Israel that
is an illegitimate tactic that no one
should associate with advocates of okay
then this prompted bynarr to actually
start justifying terrorism he loses it
he starts justifying terrorism on
national TV he's devoted her life as a
nonviolent activist to opposing an
oppression which none of us doesn't do
it does not accord with the values that
any of us believe in as a matter she
doesn't control her own organization and
what it publishes rich why don't you try
spending a little bit of time focusing
on the fact that almost four billion
dollars of US aid is used to put
children in the lanchette you're the one
distracting from the issue I'm a no
learner distraction a chiral review
shouting in offended apart a and just do
you defend it segregation you now defend
Israel's oppression of Palestinian basic
right is a tradition for you guys okay
then bind r1 even further and he
suggested that terrorism may be
justified by the fact that Israel is
oppressive and this is this is what this
is what biner has been saying for years
I mean I've been on CNN talking with
Peter Beinart and I've said openly that
this guy represents the Hamas position
he's doing all of that because and
increasingly so are members of the
Democratic Party in order to try and
make the case that Omar and Talib are
not out of bounds by nerd then tried to
defend himself and he said today I was
asked if I support Palestinian suicide
bombers god forbid a friend was killed
by one but but how is there but at the
end of that statement but Palestinians
don't forfeit their rights because some
in the midst in their midst pursue them
in an immoral way Mandela and Malcolm X
teen source violence didn't make their
oppression okay so what
now comparing Nelson Mandela to myth -
and Palestinian terrorists and all of
this to defend the evils and the
horrible viewpoints and the
anti-semitism of Rashidah Talib and ohon
Omar in a second we'll get to receipted
Talib and Ilhan Omar so Rashid to leave
in ohon Omar
hold the press conference yesterday and
in this press conference they make a
bunch of anti-semitic statements and the
democratic party again backing them to
the hilt because this is the game in the
Democratic Party they will defend their
radicals under nearly every circumstance
without even asking as to whether their
their viewpoints are radical here's
refuted Talib comparing Israel to South
Africa despite the fact that Arabs and
Muslims in Israel can vote hold
positions in the Knesset our members of
the Israeli Supreme Court that Arabic is
an official language in Israel despite
the fact that Arab Muslims in Israel are
treated better than they are anywhere in
the Arab Muslim world does not matter
we're sheeted totally ripping on Israel
calling it an apartheid state history
does have a habit of repeating itself I
learned this week that a former member
of Congress congressman Charles C Diggs
jr. was denied entry into apartheid
South Africa in 1972 he was also the
representative for the 13th
congressional district in Michigan I was
born and raised in the beautiful Detroit
where many of my african-american
teachers taught me about the realities
of oppression and justice and the need
to speak up and take action calling
Israel an apartheid state is obviously
anti-semitic because it is not in a part
I'd state and it is of course signaling
singling out Israel in a way that
Rashida - Lee would never single out
anybody else and Ilhan Omar made this
perfectly obvious and she actually
called for an end to aid to Israel I
can't imagine why Israel didn't let her
in she's literally calling for an end to
aid to Israel and a boycott of the State
of Israel I can't imagine why they
didn't allow her in to propagandize on
behalf of Israel's destruction we give
Israel more than three million dollars
in aid every year this is predicated on
there being an important ally in the
region and the only democracy in the
Middle East
we must be
asking as Israel's ally the Netanyahu
government stopped the expansion of
settlements on Palestinian land and
ensure full rights for Palestinians if
we are to give them aid okay like she
wants to give Israel aid and like you
like they're an ally okay let me be
frank about this Benjamin Netanyahu put
in unilateral settlement freeze in place
two years ago and none of these people
cared one iota about that this is all y
el hen amar Rasheeda Talib they want
Israel destroyed and they're obvious
about this and they're so disingenuous
about it as well
again the idea that she's she is a
secret ally of Israel is insane you have
to be you have to be a nutty person to
believe this sort of nonsense and she
tried her intersectional appeal she
tried to say you know people keep
calling me an anti-semite I don't know
why even though I just tried to campaign
with a group that has pushed the blood
libel sure I don't I don't know why
people keep calling me an anti-semite
you know what this is this all about
Trump trying to separate Muslims from
Jews I would go more with it is you
being a radical Jew hater I got into a
little bit of a spat with el Han Omar on
Twitter yesterday because the folks at
Media Matters doing their usual solid
work took me out of context on something
I tweeted about it
Ohan Omar then tweeted that I was both a
fool and hateful to which I tweeted back
well you know I must have hypnotized the
world using my Benjamin's but in any
case Ilhan Omar tries this
intersectional approach where she's not
an anti-semite it's just the Trump
administration trying to separate off
the Jews and the Muslims this is this is
insanity
we know Donald Trump would love nothing
more than to use this issue to pit
Muslims and Jewish Americans against
each other the Muslim community and the
Jewish community are being other and
made into the boogeyman by this
administration but but as we will hear
today people of all different faiths are
coming together to speak up against the
status quo in the region I'm grateful
for the Solidarity shown by this is this
is the myth that this is the myth that
Ilhan Omar and the Democratic Party tell
themselves the myth they tell themselves
that there is such a thing as an
intersectional coalition and they're all
on each other side and they all oppose
Trump and that's what
hold them together in the end that that
coalition will fall apart will break
apart on the shoals of its own identity
politics the fact is this Ilhan Omar she
don't like the Jews very much and it is
obvious from all of her behavior and
everything that she says that this is
the case and then she brings in token
Jews from Jewish Voice for Peace which
is a pathetic anti-israel anti-jewish
organisation and then she talks about
how pro-jewish it's insanity but the
idea is that hatred of Trump will hold
that coalition together it will until it
doesn't and will until it doesn't and
it's one of the reasons why it is
incumbent on President Trump to actually
as president trying embolden the decent
people still left in there in the
Democratic Party and there are many of
them to stand up against the hatred
inside their own party it's funny I hear
from Democrats all the time why won't
Republicans denounce people inside their
own party who say bad things if you've
ever listened to this show you know that
I do it on a regular basis you know that
I've denounced people up to an including
President Trump repeatedly for things
that they have said you know that I
maxed out to Kevin Feenstra Steve King's
opponent in Iowa right out of my own
pocket I've encouraged come Feenstra has
raised hundreds of thousands of dollars
in large part because I have had Kevin
Feenstra on my show because I think that
Steve King needs to be ousted from
Congress people in the Republican Party
are doing a much better job of standing
up to people inside their own party
Democrats are rallying around ohan Omar
and Rashida too late they're not even
asking the question Oh weird that they
would be rallying with groups that want
the destruction of the State of Israel
and openly celebrate terrorism very
weird very odd we mustn't pay attention
to it because after all the heart and
soul the Shaitan Freud the zeitgeist
signified the zeitgeist of the time
suggest that that ill Hadamard receded
to Libra in the ascendancy and I don't
think it's in the long term or even
medium term interest to the country for
the Democrats to rally around their
worst members any more than I think any
more than I think Democrats should
should root for Republicans to rally
around their worst members that they can
nut pick and then use the worst
Republicans in order to suggest that
that is the entire Republican Party okay
in just a second oh and gets you an
actual good development from Facebook
really believe it or not we'll get to
that in just one second first folks The
Daily wire has somehow managed to turn
four years old is that exciting as a
thank you to our fans we are giving away
one month of our premium monthly
subscription to anyone who uses the code
birthday which is pretty awesome
one month for free you get to try it out
and everything like to awesome that's
right for all of August as we celebrate
this milestone we are giving away a free
first month for our new premium monthly
subscribers again just use that code
birthday and come join the fun we have
all sorts of goodies that are coming I
actually finished a project last week
that is going to go out to new
subscribers sometime later this year
like there's all sorts of good stuff
that's gonna be happening it's pretty
awesome plus you're almost out of time
to purchase tickets to our backstage
live show why well because it's tomorrow
night so I mean after it happens
purchasing tickets won't do you any good
the shows happening August 21st at the
fantastic terrorist theater in Long
Beach California make the trek and then
join us me daily where god king jeremy
boring andrew Clavin michael moles will
all be there talking politics pop
culture answering your questions from
the audience
tickets are available at daily wire.com
slash backstage including our limited
VIP packages that guarantee premium
seating and photos and meet and greets
with each of us a gift from me ooh and
more tickets are almost gone so head on
over to daily wire.com slash up
backstage get yours today make the magic
happen for yourself also please
subscribe over daily wire you may have
noticed that on social media our good
friends over at Media Matters are
spending an inordinate amount of time
trying to target this show that's
because they know that the show is
dangerous to leftist point of views
that's because they know that this show
is interesting to people who disagree
with us because hell we encourage people
of all political stripes to listen and
listen to other shows too well what that
means that eventually they're going to
come after the platforms that allow us
to appear they're gonna come after our
advertisers the way you protect us the
way that you join the team is by
becoming a member over a daily wire we
really do appreciate you can see how the
platforming has has harmed all sorts of
other shows on the right you can see how
nasty people on the Left garbage people
on the left seek to take people out of
context that they can hit them and hurt
them
don't be fight fight back against it the
best way that people ask me all the time
how do I fight against that honestly it
sounds self-serving but it happens to be
true you do need to subscribe go over to
daily wire.com subscribe for $9.99 a
month or $99 a year which brings you
this he left his chair is hot or cold
tumble tumbler refilling it day in and
day out with tears from one Jason S
Campbell over at Media Matters you can
go enjoy that today for 99 bucks a year
we really appreciate where the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so let's talk about Facebook
doing something right
okay so Facebook actually did something
right
okay Senator John Kyle was brought in by
Facebook to investigate claims that
Facebook has an anti conservative bias
and I have had suspicions over the past
few years particularly in eight twenty
18 there's a facebook algorithmic change
that really hurt conservative sites in a
serious way and it turns out that there
are serious concerns that there are
serious concerns with regard to Facebook
spies but it appears that Facebook
unlike a lot of the other big tech
companies it's taking those concerns
seriously and we hear on the mend
Shapiro sure like to give credit to
people when they do the right things
even as we like to clock them when they
do the wrong things so good for facebook
so Senator Jon Kyl the Republican from a
Republican senator from Arizona he was
brought in with Covington and Burling to
do a full-scale investigation into this
and here is what they found they says we
cast a wide net using a broad definition
of conservative in order to capture for
this report the concerns raised by all
types of conservatives conservative is
an imprecise term for our purposes it
includes political conservatives people
of Orthodox religious views libertarians
Pro lifers traditionalists Republicans
and free speech advocates as an initial
step we identified key conservative
organizations individuals and lawmakers
who either use study or have the
potential to regulate Facebook since May
2018 we have interviewed approximately
133 of them we presents in our
preliminary findings to Facebook in
early August 2018 and then they
conducted a follow-up interview so here
is what they found here is what this
internal study over at Facebook led by
Senator John Kyle found and this is a
good study that is attempting to do the
right thing all of big tech should take
note Twitter particularly should take
note because that continues to run like
a garbage heap okay but Facebook is
actually trying to do the right thing
here so here is what they found there
were six categories of concerns all of
these are legit
take content distribution and algorithms
in order to sort through the thousands
of posts that Facebook users could
potentially encounter on a given day
Facebook deploys a variety of mechanisms
to prioritize the content most relevant
to each individual user conservatives
feared that these mechanisms prioritize
content in ways that suppress their
viewpoints interviewees voice three
general concerns on this front first the
January 2018 news feed algorithm change
I talked about this at the time in
January 2018 Facebook
changed its contents ranking algorithm
to favor contents that a given users
friends and family comments on and share
as well as news from quote-unquote
broadly trusted sources people on the
right weren't very concerned at
Facebook's definition of broadly trusted
sources as well we should have been this
is correct
clickbait and spam also Facebook made a
concerted effort to deprioritize
clickbait and spam interviewees
generally supported this goal but found
Facebook's policies for doing so to a
peg again that is a correct critique of
Facebook that Facebook was prioritizing
as spam headlines that didn't read like
a boring headline from the New York
Times finally fact-checking in false
news interviewees expressed significant
concerns about Facebook's efforts to
combat what the company refers to as
false news in particular interviewees
pointed to examples of instances when
some of the third-party fact checkers
utilized by Facebook at various times
snopes politifact faction or the AAP
which are certified by the Pointer
Institute an entity that owns
PolitiFact's have skewed to the
ideological left we note that Facebook
has accepted fact checkers affiliated
with conservative publishers including
the daily callers fact-checking unit
once it was approved by pointer now as I
have said for a long time using
left-wing Facebook fact-checking sites
as a proxy for actual fact checks is
nonsense PolitiFact's is wildly biased
and left so nope tries to debunk the
babylon' be every 5 minutes using them
as a proxy for fact-checking sites is
nonsense and there are no fact-checking
sites on the right the Daily Caller has
won the Weekly Standard used to have one
but then it stopped being operational
and so what Facebook needs to do is
either form their own independent
fact-checking group that includes
Republicans and conservatives and
libertarians or they need to work with
conservative groups to come up with
alternatives to PolitiFact and Snopes
and fact-check because otherwise just by
absence of right-wing fact-checking
organizations left-wing fact-checking
organizations become a club to wield
against conservative media okay so those
are three of the concerns other concerns
or content policies hate speech
designations for example interviews
concerns stemmed both from the notion of
having a hate speech policy in the first
place and from unfair labeling of
certain speech as hate speech
interviewees pointed out the highly
subjective nature of determining what
constitutes hate an assessment that may
be subject to the biases of content
reviewers also Facebook prohibits the
use of the platform by terrorists
and hate organizations and is unclear
exactly how the hate organization
designation is made especially
considering that Facebook had had been
perceived to rely on the Southern
Poverty Law Center which is a garbage
left-wing hit group so same sort of
issue as the fact checking group and
then finally there are other content
policies that that a lot of
conservatives were worried about they
believed that Facebook's community
standards were disproportionately
affecting conservative content
particularly pro-life socially
conservative religious content because
Facebook would constantly flag
conservative content so Facebook is now
responding and they're changing some of
their policies they're changing some of
their policies so they are changing
their their content enforcement policies
again this is good for Facebook like
again we should give them credit when
they're moving in the right direction
they're going to specifically try to
fight back against badly flagged content
right they're going to create the
ability to appeal decisions they are
going to change their political ad
requirements so that this is good
they're they're adding to transparency
so let's talk about some of the things
that Facebook is actually going to do so
they're going to help users understand
why they do or do not see certain
contents in their news feeds is all you
can ask from a big tech company is that
they be more transparent about what they
are doing Facebook introduced why am I
seeing this post to help users
understand why they see certain content
they are going to provide explanations
of the newsfeed rankings Facebook has
really not clarified its community
standards and newsfeed ranking but now
the company says that they want to do so
they also want to give people ways to
control their newsfeed so that you are
not going to be controlled by the great
minds over at Facebook they want to make
enforcement actions against pages more
transparent so people know exactly why
they are being flagged why they're why
their posts are being treated as bad
policy and they're going to share more
details on exactly how they create their
community standards so this is all
transparency is a good thing they're
creating an oversight board for content
decisions they will issue kind of quasi
judicial decisions on on how they are
controlling content and they're going to
include a conservative feedback in that
process as well as a public comment
period they're going to ensure that that
oversight board has viewpoint diversity
they're gonna create an appeals process
if you get flagged then you can now
appeal it and they're going to increase
staffing so that publications can reach
out to Facebook more directly they're
also going to change their advertising
policies one of the big complaints is
that Facebook had banned any ad that had
pictures of fetuses or born human babies
premature that were pro-life and now
they're changing those content policies
Facebook has historically prohibited
advertisements showing Medical tubes
connected to the human body that policy
resulted in the rejection of pro-life
ads they are changing that now so again
is this a final answer for all of
Facebook's problems no but good for
Facebook for taking this seriously
really good for them for taking it
seriously and conservatives should say
that the Conservatives should come out
and they should say when Facebook does
something right when big tech does the
right thing they should be praised this
encourages them to do the right thing
guys and I understand there is now sort
of a cottage industry and beating up on
Facebook particularly but beating up on
all of big tech and I think that a lot
of the time big tech deserves it I've
beaten up big tech my share okay but it
is because some of these companies are
better than others at dealing with the
criticism that they should be praised
when they actually deal with it in the
right way now we'll keep an eye on
Facebook and make sure that they
actually implement some of these
solutions that they continue to evolve
in their pursuit of solutions here but
good for them and don't trust anybody on
the left who's trying to make common
cause with people on the right to
regulate Facebook I do not think
Elizabeth Warren has the same priorities
on Facebook as Josh Holly I really don't
think so
so be very careful before he call for a
government regulation of big tech when
as it turns out a lot of the big tech
companies are actually seeking to not a
lot some of the big tech companies are
seeking to fix some of their internal
problems so again good for Facebook okay
meanwhile meanwhile the big story
yesterday out of New York is that the
officer in the Eric garner case was
fired that officer his name is Daniel
Pantaleo he was fired after it has now
been five years since the death of Eric
garner and that was tragic I mean Eric
garner was distributing Lucy's loose
cigarettes on the streets in New York he
resisted arrest he was put in a
in home and then he didn't die because
his windpipe was crushed or because he
was choked enough he died because the
physical stress of being put in that
hold triggered his asthma he was 395
pounds had pre-existing conditions he
had an enlarged heart that was twice
normal size and he died effectively of
asthma and a heart attack on the way to
the hospital the officer in that case
was targeted by the media as an example
of race-based policing now if you wanna
make the case that that law should have
been on the books kind of with you if
you want to make the case that the
police have been empowered to
aggressively pursue minor crimes that
should not be in fact crimes that's not
the police's fault that's the
Legislature's fault that's the City
Council's fault in New York City when
you tax cigarettes at insane rates and
then people start a black market for
cigarettes and then you empower the
police to go and force that the police
are gonna do what they're supposed to do
instead that turned into a whole racial
narrative and this particular officer
got caught up in it never mind the fact
that he was ordered by his lieutenant to
suppress this for a suppress Eric garner
who was in fact resisting arrest never
mind there were black officers on the
scene never mind that Eric garner was in
the suppression hold for a grand total
of 15 seconds no he has to lose his job
he has to be fired and then we all have
to celebrate Mayor Bill DeBlasio who was
knocked by the left for not having fired
Pantaleo he said today we saw justice
done the United States Department of
Justice absent and unwilling to act even
to come to any decision for five long
years but today we have finally seen
justice done today we saw the NYPD's own
disciplinary process act fairly and
impartially okay so that is not the
process acting fairly and impartially in
reality this was a a railroading of an
officer again I don't know that the
officer acted entirely appropriately but
this is certainly not a fireable offense
okay using a suppression hold on a
person who is resisting arrest and then
the person dies because the person
happens to have pre-existing medical
conditions not because you intended to
kill them not because you acted in
reckless and irresponsible fashion
knowing it would kill him but firing the
guy over this it's pretty clear that
this was a political process even the
why PD commissioner admitted he said
listen if I was a police officer today
I'd be very very angry at me I've been a
cop a long time and if I was still a cop
I'd probably be mad at me I would
you're not looking out for us but I am
it's my responsibility as police
commissioner to look out for the city
and certainly to look out for the New
York City police officers they took this
job to make a difference and you all
know the city's been transformed I've
had a lot of help but it's the cops out
there right now and the thousands that
have come before us that continue to
make this city safe I know some NYPD
officers I can guarantee you that they
do not feel comfortable that if they do
their jobs they're gonna be backed up by
the political forces at work in New York
City it's the same thing in Los Angeles
it's the same thing in most of our major
cities the political forces always have
an interest in throwing officers under
the bus I mean again there's this
revisionist history that has set in
around this particular case but it is
important to recognize what exactly
happened here Barry Lazar had a piece in
City Journal back in September of 2017
talking about what exactly happened he
said context is everything here the
garner case became a cause celeb because
garner was black and Pantaleo was white
and the death fit a media narrative
about interracial law-enforcement
confrontations but the facts of the
garner case demonstrate the incident
bears little resemblance to such
characterizations an NYPD lieutenant
erected Pantaleo and his partner to
arrest garner so charges that the
officer singled him out because of his
race are nonsense the arrest order was
issued because that part of Staten
Island near the ferry docks was the
subject of repeated complaints about
illegal street vendors diverting
customers from shops and even selling
drugs garner had had at least three
previous encounters with police just
that year he'd been arrested twice and
given a warning at the time of the fatal
incident he was free on bail for
offenses including selling untaxed
cigarettes driving without a license
marijuana possession and impersonation
the case against Pantaleo rests on the
supposed chokehold he used to make the
arrest he never sought to choke garner
to death or even injure him he was doing
his job taking the resisting man to the
ground as NYPD regulations provide had
garner been cooperative as the officers
requested the confrontation never would
have happened
Carter resisted when the police tried to
grab his flailing arms he says every
time you see me you want to mess with me
I'm tired of
stops today pants Illya put his forearm
around Garner's neck and twisted him to
the ground probably the simplest way of
subduing a man of Garner's girth
Pantaleo then held Garner's head down to
the sidewalk the neck hold characterized
by the medical examiner's office as a
chokehold lasted 15 seconds panto
Leone's Garner was down on the sidewalk
and that is when it became clear that
garner was actually having a serious
problem breathing he said I can't
breathe because he was suffering from
asthma apparently people didn't even
think that he was being abused there was
supervising officers at the scene
including a black police sergeant didn't
really believe even that he was in
medical distress because they didn't see
how he could be given the treatment that
he'd just received
here's the reality of Eric garner had
not had pre-existing medical conditions
not only is this not a national news
story the NYPD dismisses all charges
against penteli oh so again this is it's
an example of how politics tends to
infuse situations with import that they
do not carry I don't mean that it's not
important when a when a person dies
after being put in a suppression hold by
police for 15 seconds of course that's
important to the family of course we
should always try to keep a tight leash
on how the police act with regard to
civilians of course of course of course
but the question is in this case did
pant elio who is not prosecuted who the
DOJ investigated for five years deserved
to lose his job at NYPD over political
posturing by Bill DeBlasio and the NYPD
Commissioner I don't understand how
you're not gonna get blowback from
police officers and why you're not gonna
get another Ferguson effect police
officers saying I'm not gonna go and do
these things you want me to do because
every time I do you guys undercut us
it's the we're playing a dangerous game
here when we make the the police's
ability to do their job subject to
political whims I don't mean again the
subject to common standards of decency I
mean political whims meaning this again
this case would not have been a national
story if Pantaleo were not white or vera
garner or white it was made a national
story by the media for a particular
racial narrative and now I'll cost
Pantaleo his job and if you're a police
officer in the NYPD I'm not sure how
much trust you can have in the political
processes above you and I'm not just
saying that for me I think that it's
pretty clear from the officers I talked
to did they feel the same way okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so
that I like today Matt best is a former
member of the military and he is also
his former Army Ranger he's also a one
of the founders of our sponsors of her
black rifle coffee which is by the way
the best coffee on the market and he's
also an awesome dude I mean just a
really great dude he has a great book
out called thank-you for my service
obviously a play on thank you for your
service thank you for my service because
he says that it changed his life it made
his life an estimable better he wants to
prove every day he says that in the book
he wants to prove that not all members
of the military are sort of these
Hollywood characters who are suffering
from severe post post-traumatic stress
disorder that not every member of the
military's a broken man he's leading a
successful rich life and his book
thank-you for my service is well worth
reading so you can go check that out
ok time for a quick thing that I hate ok
so you remember that time like a week
and a half ago when Chris Cuomo got into
an altercation with somebody in public I
said at the time I blame Chris Cuomo for
getting into an altercation with
somebody in public the person was
harassing him in public
the online attitude has now spilled over
into real life
the online attitude which is that you
dunk on people and you yell at people
and you act like an ass to people has
now spilled over into real life where
people are confronting each other
publicly just to show their disdain for
one another and it's gross and as for
whether it's the right or the left
happened to me a couple of times in the
last three weeks it's it's in front of
my family it's really inappropriate and
it's disgusting and I don't blame Cuomo
for getting kicked I do blame Cuomo for
suggesting idiotically that somebody
calling him Fredo is the same thing as
calling somebody the n-word or that
Fredo is in fact a racial slur it is not
it is a specific reference to a movie
character who is seen as a weak younger
brother well one of the ways that you
don't actually get rid of that
stereotype of you as a weak younger
brother is to have your older brother
come out and defend you
so Andrew Cuomo Chris's brother came out
yesterday on the radio and he said no no
no this was a racial slur and I'm coming
out in defense of my younger brother
Fredo it fuels the hate Italian
Americans are not mafia they're not
mafia the Godfather movie don't you dare
don't you dare like in my family to them
Sam
you saw on the Godfather or The Sopranos
Mario Cuomo lived with those rumors of
the Mafia they heard him they scarred
him every Italian lives with it every
time really I know a lot of Italians
most of them I don't think walk around
being like yeah everybody keeps seeing
me as a character from the Godfather I
can't stand it also my favorite part of
this is don't you dare don't shoot hey
or what or what like what I don't want
to appear like a mafioso so I'm gonna
defend my brother by threatening you
well done Andrew Cuomo just really
strong strong stuff don't you ever take
sides against the family again hey
there's a where we are every every day
again that running gun battle for
dumbest Cuomo brother continues apace
and and it appears from that clip that
Andrew who took the lead just for a
brief moment in time okay we will be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content we will see
you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you